BORIS DEBIC: Welcome,
everybody, to one more Authors
at Google show at Google.
Today, our author is
a very special one.
He's a musical
author-- Al Di Meola.
Please give him a warm
welcome here at Google.
[APPLAUSE]
I am not going to read his
prolifically long biography.
And probably half of
you know it already,
and you can use the
search engine anyway.
You will find a lot about
him written the intertubes.
I will do a little read
up for our audiences
out there, though.
So in 1971, Di Meola enrolled
in Berklee College of Music
in Boston, and in 1974,
started his musical journey.
In addition to his
prolific solo career,
he's shared the stage with
Chick Corea, Stanley Clark,
Jan Hammer, Carlos Santana, Joan
McLaughlin, the late Paco de
Lucia, and Luciano Pavarotti
to mention just a few names
from a long list
of collaborators.
Al coinvented invented fusion,
being one of the earliest
pioneers of the genre.
And here's an interesting bit.
He also co-created the concept
of the touring trio of equals
after replacing Larry Coryell
in the acoustic guitar
group The Guitar Trio
and bring the concept
to widespread attention.
Al is a frequent at the
top of the US jazz charts.
He has amassed over
20 albums as a leader
while collaborating
on a dozen of others,
including with the
godfather of fusion,
the earlier-mentioned Larry
Coryell, and Barry Miles,
who's tape recording
launched Al's career
in subsequent
collaboration with Corea.
He has been selected 11 times
as winner in best jazz guitarist
by the Guitar Player
Magazine reader poll.
Guitar Player Magazine
is actually in San Bruno,
where YouTube is, as well.
If jazz is the original and most
influential American art forum,
then Al Di Meola
is certainly one
of its most visible contemporary
composers and performers.
He has become respected as
one of the most influential
guitarists in jazz to date.
A native of New Jersey who still
resides in the Garden State, Al
Di Meola was born in Jersey
City on July 22, 1954,
growing up in Bergenfield with
the music of Elvis Presley,
The Ventures, and the Beatles.
Please join me in welcoming
Al Di Meola to Google.
AL DI MEOLA: Thank
you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
AL DI MEOLA: It
was a great start
to the day to google
Google just to get here.
But I'm very happy to
be participating today.
Thanks for the invitation.
BORIS DEBIC: We are
honored to have you here.
AL DI MEOLA: This is great.
BORIS DEBIC: You are a
legend a lot of these people
have listened to half
their lives if not longer.
So where shall we start?
With the beginnings, I guess.
I found this little tidbit.
AL DI MEOLA: Which one?
BORIS DEBIC: That your sister
was influential in developing
you as a musician.
AL DI MEOLA: Well, only because
she was seven years older.
So she was the one--
as I was a child,
she was the one that
came home with the 45s,
with the hit records.
And I got to hear the music.
And a lot of it was
quite inspiring.
I guess the late
'50s, early '60s
were groundbreaking
in terms of sound.
The change over into
the '60s was something
that we haven't seen since-- the
most inspiring creative period
of change was during
that whole decade.
So she was largely
responsible for turning me
on to a lot of those
hits at the time.
Even the Beach Boys
were quite a sensation.
But it was the Beatles
that really did it for me.
And instrumental groups
like The Ventures
and all for the real guitar
heads, the surf bands,
and stuff like that.
And then from there, then
you had all the English music
that came over that
was groundbreaking and
revolutionary, really.
BORIS DEBIC: Indeed.
Indeed it was.
AL DI MEOLA:
Compared to the '50s.
BORIS DEBIC: So
tell me something.
How was it growing
up in New Jersey?
That's very close to--
AL DI MEOLA: It was great.
BORIS DEBIC: There's a lot
of things happening there.
AL DI MEOLA: It
is a perfect place
to grow up, because it
was quite middle class,
but it was close proximity
to New York City.
So we had all the record stores
that we needed all around us,
but we also had bus
transportation to take us
right into New York to
see the greatest shows
any night of the week.
So if I wasn't
down in the Village
seeing something at
the Fillmore East,
Bill Graham's
Fillmore East where
I got to see all
of those bands, all
of the legendary
bands from America,
from England on a weekly basis.
Just walking past Hendrix's
studio, Electric Lady Studio,
and the smell in the air,
the hippies everywhere.
It was a quite inspiring time.
And I just soaked it all in.
And then in that same period,
I was visiting Latin clubs
by myself, absorbing
the Latin music,
and then later, the jazz
clubs that were everywhere
to be found.
So I was so fortunate
to grow up in Jersey
to have that proximity as
opposed to the Midwest.
BORIS DEBIC: Did you
pick up the clubs first
or the guitar first?
AL DI MEOLA: No, the guitar.
Guitar was around
eight, nine years old.
I wasn't going to any
clubs at that time.
So did you play with Barry
before you went to college?
AL DI MEOLA: Well, Barry
Miles was the first time
I went to Berklee
School of Music,
and we discovered
Barry's records.
He's really the first fusion
guy ever, before anyone.
He kind of invented fusion.
BORIS DEBIC: OK, stop.
I've got to stop you right here.
So for people who
are 16 now and who
are like, what is this
guy talking about, fusion?
Could you illustrate to us what
is fusion, and what is the--
AL DI MEOLA: Fusion was
really the culmination
of rock blending with
elements of jazz, primarily.
BORIS DEBIC: Is there a way
to show that on a guitar,
by any chance?
AL DI MEOLA: No.
But anyway--
BORIS DEBIC: I'll get
him to take that guitar.
Trust me.
AL DI MEOLA: Of course there is.
Well, we have other elements
that we infuse-- Latin rhythms,
classical elements as well.
So I would take something
from a classical realm,
and I would syncopate the
rhythm to give it a swing.
Or it could be
something that-- it
could be a Beatles song, which
you would relate to pop music.
But some of that music had
such beautiful harmony.
Of course, it had
a great melody.
But it had beautiful
harmony, which
gives you the basis
for improvisation
if you want to do that.
Because the Beatles
really never did that.
The focus was on the
lyric and the voice
and the beautiful
song in itself.
I had the good
fortune of coming up
with the idea of
recording a record
of a collection of their work.
But then doing it at
Abbey Road made it
like going to Disney
World as a kid.
BORIS DEBIC: And we'll come
to that later on in the talk.
AL DI MEOLA: So you
can take harmony.
You can take simple harmony
and improvise on it,
maybe change the
harmony a little bit.
And then you have elements
of jazz in that sense,
because you're improvising
with scales as opposed to rock
pentatonic licks.
Rock pentatonic licks really
involve your first finger
and your third finger.
You'll never see
a rock guitarist
use his second finger,
except for when
he's mad at somebody,
and his pinkie.
How do you like that?
Watch Clapton.
He only uses his first
and third finger.
Because they're not--
BORIS DEBIC: And he's
called the god of guitar.
AL DI MEOLA: Well,
back then, he was.
BORIS DEBIC: Back then he was.
So I was thinking about this.
The trio that you later
did with Paco de Lucia
and John McLaughlin were
three equals on guitars,
come and play-- that invented,
actually, a whole new genre
of-- you had trios before.
I read somewhere that
in classical music,
there were trios in the 1800s.
But those were like a cello
and piano and something else.
It's not the same instrument.
So these guys sit together
and they play guitars
all between themselves.
I said to myself if Clapton
is the god of guitar--
and sorry for the blasphemy.
He meant it as inspiration.
Then these guys are
the holy trinity.
AL DI MEOLA: Well, it
was a certain technique
that we had-- Paco coming from
a flamenco tradition, which
John and I did not come from.
But I was kind of like the guy
in the middle, the guy that
came from a Latin background--
not necessarily flamenco--
and John coming from a whole
different kind of thing,
more Indian influenced
and very British in a way.
And so it just
worked, because we
had a certain
degree of technique
that we could communicate and
converse back and forth with.
And we were probably three
of the only guys that
could do that at that time.
So we made this record in 1980.
After two months of touring
every single night starting
in Europe, we just
built up our chops.
And we were on fire by the
time we got San Francisco,
and recorded a
record that became
this multi-zillion selling
record of a live record, which
at the time cost about
$2,000 or $3,000 to make
and sold something like
5 to 10 million copies,
somewhere in between.
We'll never know for sure
where the royalty went.
But it was a huge record
called "Friday Night
in San Francisco."
Yeah.
Some of you know it.
BORIS DEBIC: You got that.
Show it to the camera.
AL DI MEOLA: You know, there's
a number on the back of it.
It will tell me if I got paid.
Let me see.
There's a serial number on it.
No.
You owe me a buck.
Look at that, how
ridiculous I look in there.
That's great.
There's actually a "Saturday
Night in San Francisco,"
too that I have in my studio
that will be released someday
on a little chip, probably.
BORIS DEBIC: OK.
We jumped a little bit,
so I wanted to go back.
We mentioned the trio.
The trio actually
has its origins
with Larry Correal,
who was christened
the godfather of fusion.
So can you talk a
little bit about--
AL DI MEOLA: Larry was a big
hero of mine when I was a kid.
So he was really the
first guitar player
that blended all the elements.
He's really a jazz guy that
brought in rock elements
and country music elements.
Right after the heyday
of that whole rock
scene and the Fillmore East, I
was looking for something more.
And he was the guy that I became
familiar with and friendly
with.
And I actually took a lesson
from him, too, at one point.
BORIS DEBIC: Can you share the
lesson with the young viewers?
AL DI MEOLA: You want me
to remember the lesson
from when I was 15?
BORIS DEBIC: Was
it a guitar lesson?
AL DI MEOLA: Yeah, it
was a guitar lesson.
BORIS DEBIC: Oh.
I thought it was one of
those philosophical lessons.
AL DI MEOLA: Yeah.
He was tripping the whole
time, so I'm not sure
if it was usable
whatever he showed me.
BORIS DEBIC: OK.
Maybe not the right lesson
for our younger audience.
AL DI MEOLA: But
he's a wonderful guy.
He's still around.
He's kind of like the Keith
Richards of fusion music.
I don't know how he
lived through it all.
BORIS DEBIC: That's
very nice of you.
We have a couple of people who
have a burning question there.
So sir.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
Can you give us a story from
when you came to San Francisco
for that album?
AL DI MEOLA: A story about it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Something you can you.
AL DI MEOLA: Oh.
We didn't do a
lot in the States.
I think we did New York,
and we just did maybe
Chicago, and then LA
and San Francisco.
Because it was at the end
of a huge European tour.
And San Francisco
just turned out
to be the last of two months.
The chops weer really up
there, so our communication
was really quick.
And it created a good
really good environment
for the audience to witness.
I listen to those
records now, and I can't
believe how fast we played.
It's almost like, is that me?
It was a stunning performance
by those guys, too.
But it was right
around the time-- god,
I remember being--
it was probably right
around the time Lennon got shot.
Because I was at the hotel
in San Francisco, and I
saw it on the news.
It was a very memorable time.
It was December 1980.
BORIS DEBIC: I think this may
be the right time to maybe break
it for a little performance.
AL DI MEOLA: You want
to hear something?
I don't mean the
song "Something,"
but I mean something.
BORIS DEBIC: You guys
want to hear something?
[APPLAUSE]
BORIS DEBIC: All right.
Well, that's why we're here.
I would like to introduce my
percussionist of 75 years we've
been playing together.
This is Gumby Ortiz.
[APPLAUSE]
BORIS DEBIC: Thank you.
This was beautiful.
Question from the audience.
AUDIENCE: Your instruments,
Al, your guitars--
how many guitars do you own?
AL DI MEOLA: About two or three.
I sold the rest of them.
AUDIENCE: I know it's
a lot more than that.
So the other night, I had
the pleasure to see you play,
and you were playing
with a guitar
that I guess you
recorded on 20 years ago.
We're here we're in the
epicenter of technology
and technological advancements.
I found the statement you
made about that guitar--
and other musicians do as
well-- these old instruments
that play better than new.
You would think
that advancements
would occur in technology
and today's guitars
would play better.
Can you discuss that at all?
AL DI MEOLA: Yeah.
Well, acoustic guitars, as they
age, they can sound better.
Electric guitars,
sometimes the same is true.
But that one I was
playing in LA was one
that I actually sold
to someone but I used
on some of my early recordings.
So it was nice to
reconnect with it again.
Because it has a
particular sound.
Each guitar has its
own characteristics.
I was kidding, Jim.
Jim is a good friend of mine.
But I have about somewhere in
the neighborhood of 70 guitars
that I've just acquired,
but I didn't buy them all.
Companies give them
to try them out,
and they don't
ask for them back.
But out of those, maybe 10
of them are very valuable,
I would say.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
What advice would
you give to people
who are starting
out playing guitar,
even advanced but obviously
not as good as you?
BORIS DEBIC: Nobody
is as good as Al.
AUDIENCE: Becoming a
ripping guitar player,
what should I do?
AL DI MEOLA: You want to
make a living at doing this?
AUDIENCE: I think I make
a pretty good living here.
AL DI MEOLA: Playing the guitar?
AUDIENCE: No.
AL DI MEOLA: Working at Google?
AUDIENCE: Correct.
AL DI MEOLA: Stay with it.
Trust me.
I'm applying right
after this, by the way.
The music business
is getting rough.
AUDIENCE: All right I'll
take that into account.
AL DI MEOLA: Just do it for
fun, because it's really
brutal out there.
You don't want to make a career
out of playing guitar today.
Holy Christ.
You had a wonderful opportunity
in the '70s and into the '80s,
but then things declined.
Look at music today.
When you have Kanye West
out there, holy Christ.
I always seem to
just keep a quarter
note going so that
my rhythms-- I could
syncopate against the time.
And if what I syncopated
from the upper half
of the body, which is where
this happens-- none of that
would matter if the time moves.
So I could play
syncopations against it.
And what usually
happens is guitar
players think they
have-- most of them
think they have great time.
And then I'd have them in
a clinic all tap their foot
and then play a syncopation
against the time
and watch every foot go off.
So what I do is I have
everybody slow it way, way,
way down until you can get
in tune to your lower half.
Because the key for me is
that-- timing and playing
against the time.
That's what makes
it interesting.
Rhythm is the number one element
first that pulls people in.
The other elements
you can learn.
Harmony you can learn.
But as far as rhythm,
that's the thing
that grabs people immediately.
AUDIENCE: You were talking
about tapping your foot,
and I'm wondering
do you ever-- I
know you play a lot of Latin
music, like Clavier, Montuno.
Do you ever try and tap
the Clavier with your foot
as you play Montuno
just for an exercise?
AL DI MEOLA: Well, no, but
I play it on the instrument.
So if we did the
beginning of "Senor Mouse"
you know what I mean?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I just had a follow on question.
You said what happened,
and actually, I
wanted to ask you what happened.
I'm also jazz musician and
had a lot of gigs in the '80s
and early '90s, and
then they just kind of
dried up the last 10 years.
AL DI MEOLA: Oh,
you mean the scene?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the scene,
the whole jazz scene
and anything that that's
more than just a beat.
AL DI MEOLA: Well, that's
because before this
and computers, when we got into
our car, we went to the stereo.
Now we go here and we've got
to return this person's call.
And somebody's calling.
Hello?
You get to the house, you
don't run to your stereo ever.
You run to the computer.
So no one is focused anymore.
Music is important.
We need music to survive,
or as a society, we go nuts.
But it became secondary.
Whereas before these things--
these are wonderful things,
by the way-- we were
totally focused,
just like musicians in a studio.
I have my band
record-- not Gumby.
He's the only one that
comes from the old school.
I'm saying that because
he's here right now.
He knows it.
But not, that's true.
So we'd cut a take,
and they'd all
go out in the hallway
on their computers,
checking their emails
and checking their text
and everything while I'm in
listening to the playback.
Now, back in the '70s, we'd
all rush into the control room,
because we were all involved.
That's why those records from
that period sound phenomenal.
Everybody was focused.
Today, we have too
many variables,
too much to choose
from, too many people,
too much networking.
We're networking
all over the place.
So the focus is gone.
That's my take on it.
And I think I'm right.
AUDIENCE: Once you established
yourself in the US,
you started traveling around.
AL DI MEOLA: I was at
Berkeley School of Music,
and I got a call from
Chick to join the band.
He says, I heard this tape that
your friend might play for me.
And I've got to tell
you, we're knocked out.
We'd love for you
to join the band.
Could you come to
New York like now?
We had about two or three
days rehearsal and 11 charts,
about seven pages long.
And luckily, I knew
how to read music.
And I was scared out of my mind.
Because Return to Forever was
my favorite band at the time--
electric guitar in the
forefront kind of band.
And that was one of the
three pioneering fusion
bands-- Weather Report being
one, Mavishnu Orchestra,
and Return to Forever.
And Return to Forever
was maybe even more so,
because it was the
compositional band.
It had the most intricate
compositions and interesting.
So I was more influenced by
Chick and Return to Forever.
And Beatles were my
other favorite band,
but I knew there was ever
a way for that to happen.
But those were my
two favorite bands.
And funny thing is, we went into
the studio-- I was still 19--
we did Carnegie Hall, and
then we did some stadiums.
Part of the Newport
Jazz Festival,
we did Houston Astro
Dome, Cincinnati Stadium,
Atlanta Stadium as part of
this whole big festival thing.
And then we went right
into the studio in New York
at the record plant.
And speaking of the
Beatles, John Lennon
was in the next room.
So I got to peak in
every now and then
and watch him at the
board doing his thing.
I was in a state of shock
with the whole thing.
It was a dream come true.
BORIS DEBIC: What do you
think of-- so guitar in Africa
is very interesting.
And we know there's a
lot of musicians, very--
AL DI MEOLA: Africa?
BORIS DEBIC: In Africa, yes.
AL DI MEOLA: It's very,
very rich for music.
BORIS DEBIC: Yes.
But what about-- I'm puzzled
by this lack of-- there's
a lot of people in Asia.
I managed to find a
couple of composers which
compose for guitar in China.
But that's really
classical stuff.
It's not the popular stuff.
There are performers
in Japan, I guess.
That's where you can find them.
AL DI MEOLA: We haven't found
a lot from China that's--
BORIS DEBIC: Do they
miss an Al Di Meola
touring a little bit there
and opening their eyes
to the instrument?
AL DI MEOLA: I don't
know about China yet.
I think it's the next frontier
that should and could open,
like Russia opened.
And I've toured all over
Russia-- Siberia, all
across the 11 time zones.
When that opened,
that was really cool.
BORIS DEBIC: They did have the
balalaika through centuries
as well.
AL DI MEOLA: Huh?
BORIS DEBIC: They did have the
balalaika through centuries.
AL DI MEOLA: Yeah.
But they had a tremendous
understanding and depth
of appreciation for the music.
Unbelievable.
China, I don't know,
except for Hong Kong
I played a number of times.
But it was a little bit
different than mainland.
I haven't yet done that.
I've done Korea
a number of times
and Japan a whole lot of times.
BORIS DEBIC: What is your take?
AL DI MEOLA: The Mideast
is very interesting,
because there's been
a great demand for me
to play in places like Iran.
And I'd love to
do that, actually.
And there, I could
be an ambassador.
I'd probably get this nuclear
arms thing straightened out.
I would request that
I have a meeting
with one of the
guys, the mullahs
or whatever his name is.
I can't forget North
Korea, because I
want to get some o
that money Rodman got.
Anyway, that's another story.
I played in places like
Tunisia and Algeria.
Last year, we played Algeria.
And the appreciation for
the music is out of control.
It's really great.
Way greater than
even New Jersey.
BORIS DEBIC: There
you go, New Jersey.
We have questions there.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm just curious-- could
you give us a little bit
of a background of how you
evolved to who you are today
from your family atmosphere as
a child and how you got the--
AL DI MEOLA: Well, I had
the typical Italian American
tension in the house.
So I would go upstairs
to get away from it.
And that kind of stress I
took out on my instrument.
It was actually wonderful.
It was a very secure
feeling having
parents right there down
below and my own little space
upstairs to listen and dream.
And the proximity
to New York, going
to the shows-- and a friend
of mine a few houses away
had an amazing garage
where we practiced.
And it was just a perfect
childhood experience.
So I evolved, I
guess, because I felt
it very early on that
I was going to do this.
I wanted to make it
when I was young.
And I had a drive that became
super strong after an accident
I had that where I
almost lost my life.
And right after getting out of
the hospital after two months,
I had this tremendous
burning drive to do this.
So it could be a little
connection to upstairs.
I'm not sure.
BORIS DEBIC: To
the pearly gates?
AL DI MEOLA: But
that's what happened.
Yeah.
BORIS DEBIC: All right.
So now we're going to do it a
little bit of machine learning
stuff.
So machine learning
is a way for computers
to do stuff on their own.
So they don't need
programmers and all that.
And I thought it
would be a good thing
to construct a feature
vector out of you.
And these guys understand
what I'm talking about.
But the idea actually comes
from the Actor's Studio series
with James Lipton.
He does the Proust
questionnaire.
I thought ah, that
would be interesting.
So he has already a
whole bunch of actors.
Let's do a guitarist, and then
the machine learning people
will be able to
differentiate and figure out
how to build the perfect guitar
playing computer in 357 years.
So are you up for it?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
Fire away.
BORIS DEBIC: I'll
shoot the question.
And this is supposed
to be answered quickly,
because we don't want
you to think too much.
It's from the heart.
What is your favorite word?
AL DI MEOLA: My favorite work?
BORIS DEBIC: Word.
AL DI MEOLA: Word.
[SIGHS] That was it.
Let's see.
My favorite word.
Don't think too much, right?
[SPEAKING ITALIAN]
It's an Italian word.
BORIS DEBIC: What is
your least favorite word?
AL DI MEOLA: Can't do it.
Can't.
BORIS DEBIC: What turns you on?
AL DI MEOLA: Music.
BORIS DEBIC: What turns you off?
AL DI MEOLA: Rap.
BORIS DEBIC: What sound
or noise do you love?
AL DI MEOLA: My
daughter and my fiance.
BORIS DEBIC: What sound
or noise do you hate?
AL DI MEOLA: My ex.
BORIS DEBIC: What is
your favorite curse word?
AL DI MEOLA: There's so many.
Fuck.
BORIS DEBIC: What profession
other than your own
would you like to attempt?
AL DI MEOLA: Fireman.
BORIS DEBIC: What profession
would you not like to do?
AL DI MEOLA: Janitor.
BORIS DEBIC: What is your--
AL DI MEOLA: Oh, I should've
said to tour manager.
I'm sorry.
He's sitting right there.
I missed a chance.
BORIS DEBIC: Give a hand to
the touring manager, please.
[APPLAUSE]
AL DI MEOLA: It's a brutal job.
I wouldn't want to work for me.
BORIS DEBIC: What is
your favorite chord?
AL DI MEOLA: My favorite
chord, very good.
It's a seven flat nine.
BORIS DEBIC: What is your
least favorite chord?
AL DI MEOLA: My
least favorite chord
is just a plain major chord.
BORIS DEBIC: Any in particular?
AL DI MEOLA: C.
BORIS DEBIC: And the last
one-- if heaven exists,
what would you like
to hear God say when
you arrive at the pearly gates?
AL DI MEOLA: You did great.
BORIS DEBIC: Get
him a hand, please.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you, Al.
All right.
What are you doing
these days, and what
keeps your interests
fired up, so to speak?
And where are you going?
AL DI MEOLA: I try to
remain inspired or find
new inspiration to write.
I love writing music.
And sometimes, you go
into these little lulls
where you're looking
for something new.
There were periods in
which I had that, and then
all of a sudden,
something would come up.
Like when I discovered the music
and then developed a friendship
with the late great tango
master Astor Piazzola,
that was a pivotal
time in my career,
because it really exemplified
the biggest change
in my direction, my thinking,
and thought process,
and music-- connecting
intellectual with the heart.
What he was producing on his
own was very sentimental,
but at the same time,
very intellectual.
With fusion music, it
was going more cerebral,
but it wasn't so much
affecting the heart.
I saw that direction
going the wrong way.
And it made me
reconnect to the music
that I loved when I was a
kid that really did touch me.
And it could be something
as simple as the Beatles.
So the melodies were so
everlasting and beautiful.
So I wanted to create
with that in mind
more often, so I let
that become an influence.
So every often, you
look for something
like that to influence you.
Last record was a
tribute to the Beatles,
and then the new one
that's coming out
is a collection of all of
my influences up to 2015.
So they're all original pieces.
And it really shows
where I've come from,
and where I'm at
now, and what I've
accumulated along the way
in terms of influence.
BORIS DEBIC: I'm
kind of surprised
that nobody has yet picked up
a large portion of their movie,
for example, used your music.
I thought that was
kind of strange.
AL DI MEOLA: I'm only found in
The Sopranos for some reason.
Something to do with
north Jersey, I think.
BORIS DEBIC: Do we have
any audience questions?
AUDIENCE: More
toward the beginning,
you talked about
loving pop and working
way up through Venture's
instrumental stuff to the pop.
How do you make the
transition from that
to being in Berkeley
and being proper jazz
and then coming out with this--
at the time, nobody did what
you did, which was playing
very fluidly-- rock-ish,
but playing real jazz as
opposed to just plugging an art
shop into a fuzz box.
AL DI MEOLA: My teacher from
the age of nine years old
was an old school jazz buff.
So he was into Johnny Smith,
Tal Farlow, and Howard Roberts,
and that kind of thing.
And he taught me chord
positions, jazz chords, scales,
alternate picking.
So I was already halfway there
by the time I got to Berkeley.
In fact, more than
halfway there.
They wanted me to teach at
Berkeley when I got there,
and I really wanted to
just continue my education.
But having the
experience of seeing
all of my favorite
groups and absorbing
all the great Latin music of
New York, all those great clubs,
and then having that background
with the my jazz teacher
made me an oddball in a sense.
Because I didn't fit into any
of the local-- around my town,
they had a bunch of
local bands, and they
couldn't figure me out.
Because that style
wasn't befitting of a lot
of that kind of rock music.
So I was really on the
outside of that stuff
until after Berkeley, that
little short stint in Berkeley,
and then I get this
call from Chick Corea,
and all of a sudden,
I'm on the front page
of a lot of magazines.
With this style, it was at the
forefront of the fusion guitar.
BORIS DEBIC: So we'll
do another number?
AL DI MEOLA: Yeah.
[APPLAUSE]
BORIS DEBIC: Gumby Ortiz.
My man.
And Al Di Meola, of course.
Good job, Al.
AUDIENCE: I'm
curious-- you mentioned
being inspired by the Beatles.
Yet the music that you
play and the musicians
that you've played with are
heavily jazz influenced.
And that's arguably, from
a technical standpoint,
incredibly complex, really
difficult music to play.
So reconciling those two
different influences--
what do you think ultimately
makes a good musician?
Because arguably, the Beatles
weren't incredible guitarists,
but they were great songwriters.
And you've played with
incredible guitarists
and incredible musicians.
So I guess what do you
think makes a good musician?
AL DI MEOLA: They told
stories with words.
If you eliminate
the words, it feels
like there's something
missing unless you do
something really hip with it.
So instrumental music
for me had to go beyond.
We had to incorporate more
into the soup in order
to make it more interesting.
So if I had a
voice, I definitely
wouldn't be doing this.
You get what I'm saying?
Yeah.
Plus, there were a lot
of different influences.
Beyond learning
the basics-- which
you can have a great career
just with the basics, maybe even
a better career.
There's a lot of pop bands
that don't know that much.
They know maybe five,
six, seven chords,
and they've written
tremendous hits
that sold millions of records.
But I got to a point
where-- especially
when you think about the Beatles
when they stopped and they went
off on their own
with John and Yoko,
that was some bizarre stuff.
I lost some interest.
And I wasn't a big
Paul fan with Wings
like other people
might have been.
And I lost some interest.
And I wanted to continue
learning the instrument,
get more advanced on it.
And that's when my world
opened, and I heard Miles Davis.
And Miles was really
the first jazz musician
who comes from the post-pop
thing and then got into fusing
the music.
Because he became
so influenced by Sly
and the Family
Stone, which I loved,
and Jimi Hendrix and all.
Even his clothes--
he was outrageous.
He was totally into
the rock thing.
So he came out with a record
called "Bitch's Brew."
And all the guys
playing on that record--
like Chick Core,
Joe Zawinul, who
started Weather Report, John
McLaughlin, Mahavishnu, Billy
Cobham-- they're all on
that record, Wayne Shorter.
And they all went off to form
their own pioneering groups
of that era.
But it all started with that.
And none of them can sing.
BORIS DEBIC: Thank you, Al.
You have a busy schedule
today, and we don't want
to mess up with your schedule.
I want to thank you--
AL DI MEOLA: This
was a pleasure.
BORIS DEBIC: On behalf of
everybody here in this room.
AL DI MEOLA: Thank you.
It was a lot of fun.
BORIS DEBIC: And all of the
people who will watch this.
[APPLAUSE]
Let's give a standing
ovation, please.
Come on, guys.
AL DI MEOLA: Thank
you very much.
BORIS DEBIC: Take a bow, Al.
Take a bow.
[APPLAUSE]